okay baby here i come
this is the doctor talking to you
jeanie mai and her husband jeezy are
enjoying all the milestones that come
along with pregnancy including listening
to their baby's heartbeat
we landed on it
this is your daddy
this is your daddy
the 42 year old tv host shared the
touching moment on instagram tuesday her
pregnant belly on full display as her
hubby uses an at-home ultrasound to get
a little closer to their baby to be
genie's caption he changed my playlist
forever okay baby j here come
this is the doctor talking to you
we landed on it
he landed right on it
see because we go
there
right there
this is your daddy
this is your daddy huh hi baby hi baby
this was very emotional for me the
dancing with the stars alum revealed
she's expecting a little one on monday
during the season eight premiere of her
daytime talk show the real
we had so much to reveal here at the
show
including the fact that
i am pregnant
[Applause]
the news is particularly emotional for
jeannie who revealed in a recent
interview with women's health that the
couple experienced a pregnancy loss just
before their march wedding
love can really change you well wow um
and
i'm so thankful to be on a show that's
really helped me to grow and to evolve
and to see myself differently than i
would have ever imagined seeing myself i
feel like you all individually always
told me to that if i wanted to be a mom
yes no i would argue with you
me and jeannie full-on would have
arguments behind the stage and i'm like
you'd be an amazing mother but before
jeannie could celebrate with her girls
on tv she told them privately backstage
naturally she wanted to get their
genuine reactions so she set up a camera
in their conference room and the footage
does not disappoint
i am kind of bothered because you guys
even though i've said like what i want
to do what i'm not gonna do what i'm
never gonna do
you never stop me to remind me that
a god is always in control
and b that
it would be possible that i would fall
in love with somebody
meet somebody who would completely
change the way that i looked at life
and so i wanted to tell you guys first
off that i'm pregnant
[Applause]
yeah lots and lots of screaming for baby
jenkins
thank you i appreciate that i wanted you
guys to know about it first again you
should have told me never say never
oh my god oh my god can i touch you yes
it's a little snowman
oh my god do you know what you're here
no and once you're in the real fam
you're there for life check out these
sweet text messages jeannie shared on
her instagram story with her former
co-host tamera maury housley welcoming
genie to the mom club
you know i'm already planning it back in
june e.t chatted with jeannie all about
another big change in her life becoming
a missus
how is married life and how does it feel
different
married life feels 1 000 different than
when we were dating
in the greatest way she explained you
really can have it all
we want to feel trusted we want to feel
loved we want to feel safe we want to
feel cuddles we want to feel you know
the romance we want to feel dating want
to be hot and heavy with sex like you
want all those things so
human beings want those same things why
can't you communicate exactly what that
should look like in order to customize
the relationship you have and work
towards it and so the fact that i'm
doing that with a partner that is
like-minded with me is the best part of
my life
[Music]
you